um so in europe
i'm the best i think i'm the best
defender to ever play this game
in nba yeah my 100
that's my opinion but you know i
i also think i view the game a lot
differently than most people view the
games i think i just see it from a
different
perspective you know and um
i just don't think you know i think when
you look at
the things that make a great defender
reaction time toughness uh
being able to see the picture long
before it
develops
and most importantly in order to finish
a defensive possession you got a rebound
and i
you know i think i rebound well and so
uh you know when i look at all of
all the facets that make up the
defensive side of the ball
i think i am i think i'm great in
every facet that makes up that side of
the ball
so i think i'm the best defender to ever
play in the nba
and i stand by that i'll put myself up
against anyone
that caused a lot of reaction tony allen
another great defender came out and said
you can't just
christen yourself that draymond green
said yeah i can i
when it was here it is he said big cap
who stamped you
who you clamp in the words of jay-z we
don't believe you you need more people
draymond green then responded to that
are you laughing at me reading that
these lyrics is giving me life
check check out shaq's ig i was waiting
on you to stamp me big homie but your
stamp book started running low in 2015
when we used you against your team on
the way to my first
championship i turn to you oh like yo
stamp book now because it's four on five
out there right now my boy
hashtag call clay i think draymond is a
most complete i don't know the best he's
the most complete defensive player of
the year
he said ever though it's no way to say
ever
that's just crazy and whoever's whoever
agrees
whoever agrees with him or ever you
don't know basketball and
draymond should say what he says yeah
two things can be right two things could
be right if i'm draymond
i totally agree draymond from the glove
he got hard he's been doing it since
college he had a triple-double without
scoring he's the man defensively he'll
shut everybody down but
i just like reminding people some names
yes
bill russell um yeah like i
just should just feel like i had a big
glove with some
baby powder and just go smack everybody
in the world and say you ain't say
bill russell kobe
okay kg
kg seven foot checking one twos and
threes no
draymond is the man i just let's all
have a great you know comments
yeah yeah uh yeah dennis roberts robin
how how did dennis robin go play with
jordan to shut down magic well didn't
shut down nobody
yeah you know play with magic playing
with magic at the lakers
here with the chess chris you know what
i'm saying i'm just saying if i'm
draymond i'm saying 100
and in the game today i don't have a
quorum i just have a coin with anybody
in the world says
ever that's all that's that's all but
he's the man he has clearance they won
he has heart and i think the main thing
he was right about
in every facet of the game seeing the
play before it happened rebounding
and candice you know this starting to
break being able to throw it up the big
shack or something like me i would have
loved to play with him because we would
have been
you know we would have been known so i
definitely think you know he's great but
i just think you can't say ever all
right so you never said
i'm one of the best power forwards ever
because i think you are
thank you okay and that's a compliment
come from you and i always say one up
nah if it's me or my boy and again he's
right
hold on during our battles you never
said i'm the best powerful
ever in the league in my head i always
believe okay god
always believe you know what i'm saying
but saying ever in a group of you know
from the world it's not my boys but then
again i don't know if anybody has punked
as many people as draymond in the league
right even through this statement you
know what i mean so again i agree with
him but just
remember bill russell you know i
appreciate the fact that you put the
baby powder on before you smack
everything yeah yeah